So today, I'm going to be talking about a trial that just opened through our SWOG
clinical trials partnership. It's called LUKE-01. And this is a phase two trial of
blenitumumab, dasatinib, prednisone, and blenitumumab in patients with Philadelphia
chromosome positive ALL. So just as some background, Philadelphia positive ALL is
characterized by the Philadelphia chromosome. And we see this actually more commonly in about
50% of patients that are greater than 50 years of age. And so this is relevant because it tends
to be an older patient population with more comorbidities. Historically, this was associated
with a very poor prognosis. And really, the only curative treatment option was allogeneic transplant.
But things have now changed significantly.
With the incorporation of TKIs, as well as now with blenitumumab.
So some initial data that was done by Dr. Foa and colleagues, they looked at TKI and steroids.
And the response rates with dasatinib and prednisone were extremely high,
a 93% complete remission rate by complete hematologic response by day 22.
The main issue was...
The main issue was with just this approach, the disease-free survival at 20 months was only about
51%. So these remissions were not very durable. They did show that MRD
correlated with disease-free survival. And of the patients that relapsed, a significant number
of patients had a T315I mutation that was in the B-serum abel kinase domain.
So subsequently, there's now been nice work done by many groups looking at incorporating blenitumumab
with TKI and steroids into frontline treatment. Blenitumumab is a bispecific T-cell engaging
antibody that targets CD19. It was initially approved by the FDA for relapse refractory B-cell
ALL, and then for MRD-positive ALL.
And so this is data from two studies. One is the FOA study. In this study, they combined
blenitumumab with dasatinib and steroids. They have now presented long-term follow-up.
Their patient population was a younger patient population with a median age of 54.
In their study, they did have about 24 out of 63 patients did undergo allogeneic transplant.
So that may impact some of these results. And with a median follow-up of 53 months,
they had very excellent disease-free overall and event-free survival. But again, in those
patients that relapsed, they did see T315I mutations.
Through SWOG, we conducted a study very similar, but this study was limited to patients 65 years
of age and older. In this study, only one patient was able to get a T315I mutation.
And so this study was limited to patients 65 years of age and older. In this study,
only one patient was able to get a T315I mutation. And so this study was limited to patients 65 years of age and older. In this study, only one
patient was able to get a T315I mutation. And so this study was limited to patients 65 years of age and older. In this study, only one
patient actually underwent an allogeneic transplant. This median age here was 73 years.
And the median follow-up we just presented at ASH this year was 5.6 years.
And again, the results are not quite as good as FOA, but again, in an
older patient population, and only one person undergoing transplant.
And so the question is, can we improve upon these results? And particularly, can we try
to decrease the risk of relapses with patients with T315I mutations?
And so the MD Anderson group has done some very nice work looking at using panatinib with
blenatumumab with excellent results and overall survival. The main issue has been that for some
of our older patients with cardiovascular comorbidities, blenatumumab may be problematic.
And so the question is, can we improve upon these results? And so the question is, can we try to
improve upon these results? And so the question is, can we try to improve upon these results? And so the question is, can we try to get around this?
And so a siminib is, it basically isn't able to directly, works differently than the other
B-cerebral inhibitors, and has been shown to be active against T315I mutations.
And so there's been data showing that this allosteric inhibitor or a siminib in combination
with an ATP-competitive TKI may be able to deepen clinical responses and reduce the resistance of
emergent mutations. And so this is the LUCA1 trial that we have currently just opened. It hasn't
enrolled any patients yet. This is able to be opened through any SWOG sites.
And basically, the regimen is very similar to the FOA regimen, but we're looking at a siminib
and desatinib with steroids as induction. Patients then get post-remission treatment
with a siminib and desatinib, followed by blenatumumab, desatinib, and then maintenance
with a siminib, desatinib, and prednisone. And so the primary objectives are to assess
the rate of major molecular remission by PCR. Cecilia Yung and Jerry Radich are also going to
do some nice correlative work in their lab, evaluating and describing genes and pathways
that are associated with response to therapy, as well as really looking at the spectrum of
mutations that we observe and the timing of resistance.
And so in conclusion, outcomes have really improved significantly, and most patients are now
receiving blenatumumab with TKI therapy. I think we really are going to need longer follow-up to
assess these outcomes, or follow-up even on these studies is still short. So the challenges that
remain, I think I still struggle if you have a very young patient that's in their 20s and 30s.
Most of us are doing blenatumumab and TKI, but I think we don't know what's going to happen
20 and 30 years down the road. We, I think, need to learn how to prevent,
and treat these resistant mutations. And also, one area that we've seen presented by both MD
Anderson and other groups has really been now that we're starting, in some of these higher-risk
patients, we're starting to see CNS relapse, or CNS disease. And so how do we help with this?